[Music]
i took a break from my job after working
for seven years due to pregnancy
and two years later i joined back but
something was missing
and the technology had also evolved i
have always been interested in the field
of data science and consulting and
although i had a solid experience
my career break made it difficult to
find a job as an analyst
so i decided to upscale myself with
simply learns business analysis masters
program and after completing the course
i got hired by tech mendra as a senior
business analyst
hi my name is shruti ayar and i work as
a senior business analyst at tech
mahindra i completed my graduation in
electronics and telecommunication
engineering in 2008 and joined ibm
when i tried applying for various other
companies after a career break i felt
the need to bridge the gap in my skills
and that's when i decided to upskill so
i searched various platforms
while there were lot of videos on
youtube they were not organized there
were other platforms offering courses
that did not have a fixed schedule and
expert trainers
i wanted to upskill quickly but from a
good place
therefore i chose simply learn as my
upscaling partner
the thing that i liked the most about
simply learn is that the entire content
is very organized with a proper schedule
for the learner
one can get better with practical
exposure due to the live sessions and
projects
which helps in understanding various
concepts the course certification helped
me to a great extent in getting
shortlisted for the interview it was a
great experience for me because i lacked
confidence after a long gap
i hope to lead the data scientist team
in the future
you should not be afraid to plan
anything if you want to go for it please
don't wait for tomorrow do it today